on va passer à philippe gildas on va
faire un hommage à philippe gildas parce
que j'ai eu la chance de le rencontrer
j'ai eu la chance de travailler avec lui
avec valérie bénaïm d'ailleurs vous
étiez avec nous sur l'émission les pieds
dans le plat sur europe 1 et cette
séquence aujourd'hui elle est pour lui
elle est pour philippe et j'embrasse
très très fort marri sa femme qui est un
amour et je lui dis que je pense très
très fort elle c'est parti le décodeur
du post il a marqué le monde de la
télévision et de la radio pour les plus
jeunes qui nous regardent c'était une
figure emblématique de europe 1 et canal
plus son émission nulle part ailleurs
avait fait son succès c'est vrai que
vraiment philippe gildas vous avez vous
l'avez rencontré jennifer il avait
rencontré jamais mais c'est vrai que ça
c'est une belle journée creuse pendant
17 ans et que ce soit pour les jeunes ou
pour les plus âgés ça reste une légende
ça reste quelqu'un voilà moi avec qui
j'ai passé des moments formidables et je
vous le dis c'est pour ça que je voulais
absolument qu'on mette cette faute
aujourd'hui c'est que philippe gildas et
ça a toujours un sourire
il était toujours souriant quoi qu'il
arrive il était toujours souriant on le
voyait nous le matin dans les pieds dans
le plat toujours avec le sourire
toujours élégant et rien toujours
il voulait toujours apprendre quelque
chose ou faire apprendre quelque chose
regardez on a retracé sa carrière c'est
parti philippe gildas c'était avant tout
un visage emblématique de l'esprit canal
des années 90 pendant ces cinquante six
ans de carrière il a été aux commandes
de nombreuses émissions de radio sur
europe 1 rtl et de plusieurs émissions
télé comme la tête et les jambes
bonsoir ou la chasse au trésor bonifacio
c'est la bacb room philippe de
dieuleveult à la tête de son équipe avec
comédie copper il est également
l'inventeur de l'émission culte le top
mais ce qui marquera le plus sa carrière
ce sont ces dix années à la tête de
l'émission nulle part ailleurs
ouais c'est l'embrouillé
[Applaudissements]
de 1987 à 1997 philippe gildas aura des
milliers de fous rires avec de koné
garcia il accompagnera l'explosion de
programmes cultes comme les nuls ou
encore les guignols de l'info à ce que
tu l'avais déjà vu de près est pas
terrible
il découvrira de nombreux talents comme
jérôme bonaldi qui aura du mal à
découvrir comment fonctionnent les
objets qui vient présenter ça va faire
quoi
bref ce n'est pas seulement un grand
présentateur qui s'est éteint ce
week-end c'est le visage de la pop
culture de l'humour et de l'irrévérence
des années 90 et restera de philippe
gildas des milliers de souvenirs
inoubliables et une grande partie de nos
meilleurs moments télé
[Musique]
il nous a quittés à 82 ans
un exemple pour tous les jeunes qui nous
regarde ce qu'ils veulent faire ce
métier vraiment c'est un exemple
philippe gildas daniel moment où vous
l'avez bien connu et lavez vous l'avais
interviewé plaint de quoi exactement est
la dernière fois il ya quelques mois
avec maryse parce que sa femme
indissociables donc avec sa femme ils se
chamaillaient comme un vieux couple
évidemment si on leur souvenir mais mais
on se rend pas compte à quel point il a
inventé des choses c'est à dire que les
matinale de la radio ça semble une
évidence maintenant c'est lui qui l'a
inventée dans les années 60 sera du
luxembourg avant rtl
on lui doit on lui doit les flashs les
titres tout ce qui fait maintenant les
matinales radio c'est c'est lui on lui
doit donc le top 50 on lui doit les
restos du coeur parce que sans philippe
gildas coluche aurait et coluche était
très mal vu à l'époque un il avait il
était mal vu dans la rédaction des
repères les journalistes ne lui parlait
même pas idée des personnes en gras
philippe gildas patron d'europe 1 ce
moment là qui a vraiment facilité les
choses
il a même fait découvrir sa soeur
emmanuelle dans les années soixante dix
c'est lui qui a été au caire et entendu
parler d'une soeur formidable moitié
belge boîtier française il a fait une
interview où elle a été rediffusé je ne
fais confiance et il a fait don vraiment
il a fait découvrir alors qu'ils sont
négociées ce moment où antoine de caunes
déguisés en john embrouilles à effet
sortir philippe gildas du plateau au
regard des bêtes à gommer les sept au
rouge brusquement
que moi non tu vois serein j'ai fait un
ville
aujourd'hui on averses les rôles allez-y
les gars des masters
[Applaudissements]
et je les regardais quand est ce que
vous vous rappelez il ya le plein de
dérapages dont 1 voilà au corps à cause
du duo josé garcia et antoine de caunes
fin cause grâce si on a envie de lire
rappelez vous de ce jour où le duo avait
totalement redécoré le plateau regardez
je suis dit oh et noir 6
[Applaudissements]
à
je n'ai qu'un seul
[Applaudissements]
voilà philippe gildas qui va beaucoup
d'augmenter on pense très très fort à sa
famille à ses enfants à sa femme est
vraiment voilà c'était voilà un exemple
pour nous et je voudrais dire voilà on a
eu la chance de travailler avec lui et
ça restera toujours gravé dans nos
mémoires
valérie bénaïm complètement absolument
vraiment c'était quelqu'un qui était
extrêmement bienveillant et qui vous ne
vous écrasez jamais de tout ce qu'ils
avaient pu faire de plus que vous bien
évidemment ils étaient tous j'étais là
vraiment comme passeur tout le temps et
20 sur philippe voilà je vous le dis on
t'oubliera jamais et vraiment on t'aime
très fort voilà merci merci d'avoir fait
plus tout à fait fini
[Applaudissements]